tv.org i'm tony clark from the carter
presidential library we're really glad
that you could join us tonight um and in
fact i think it's it's really good i
happen to be a johnny cash fan and so
i'm really interested in this but it's
also appropriate for the carter library
because
president carter used to joke that he
was a cousin of
june carter cash um though that probably
may not be true um but it's it's going
to be a really interesting evening to
get the political side of johnny cash as
you'll probably hear tonight
president carter was one of i think a
couple of
presidential candidates that uh
johnny cash said that he
he supported
michael stewart foley is our author
tonight michael grew up in new england a
typical
irish-american family
uh family moved around a lot when he was
a kid six times four years seven years
old but there were a couple of things
that were really consistent in his
family
they were
really political from the the standpoint
they they loved politics national and
local politics they were democrats
pro-union loved fdr and jfk
but his father also stressed the
importance of the ability to write
as he put it
you needed to have a command of the
english language in order to succeed and
and michael combined all of those things
it's a great background for the
preparation for
citizen cash the political life and
times of johnny cash
in addition to this book michael has
written or edited seven other books
including confronting the war machine or
front forged politics
he is a historian of popular culture and
a historical advisor to films and tv
shows like mad men and he's also a
professor of american civilization
at his home in france
also joining us tonight is historian and
georgia state university professor john
mcmillan
john is the author of a number of books
including american epidemic
reporting from the front lines of the
opioid crisis smoking typewriters
the 60s underground press and rise of
alternative media
beetles and stones and he is the
co-founder
or co-founding editor rather of the 60s
the journal of history politics and
culture we're going to have a
conversation between the two of them but
all of us
in the audience will get a chance to ask
questions at the bottom of the screen
there is a little place where you can
type in your question and i'll be
monitoring that and we'll get to those
uh in just a little bit so
now it's time to sit back and learn
about uh johnny cash and so gentlemen
michael and john i'll turn it over to
you
thank you
thanks for the great introduction yes
absolutely and um
well i i think i've done a couple events
with help from the carter center and a
cappella books and it's just a great
pleasure thank you very much for hosting
both of us i wish we could be together
in person
um but this will have to do
one reason i want to be and i would like
to be in person is because mike and i
are really good friends so i'll just say
that from the outset we've known each
other for about 20 years and it's been a
really
rewarding and wonderful friendship
uh during that period
and it occurred to me just recently that
over that 20-year period there have been
many times that i've heard you talk
about this book
which is coming out now though there's a
long gestation period
as tony just mentioned you've done a lot
of other things in the in the intro
i liked the in the introduction you told
a story about the the first and only
time
that you went to a high-end auction and
it was an auction that was selling uh
johnny cash memorabilia which you
acknowledge you could not have afforded
you had an interesting and edifying
experience there i wondered if you would
just
start by sharing that
uh sure thanks i mean uh this speaks
exactly to the point you just made that
you've heard me talking about johnny
cash for 20 years because
this was in
2004 right
after
cash and june carter had both passed
away and the estate was auctioning off
all of their
affairs at sotheby's and
i had i had been working on this other
book that tony mentioned about the
vietnam war
and in 2002 uh sony and or colombia had
come out with this concert recording
that had never been released before it
was from december of 1969
that was recorded at madison square
garden and at which
johnny cash starts speaking uh quite a
lot in fact about the vietnam war so
that had really piqued my interest
because i was a cash fan and i didn't
know that he even had said anything
about the vietnam war until i heard that
recording
so when the auction
was taking place i decided to just go
check it out not really sure what i
would learn
and
i was about to give up in fact because i
thought this is kind of pointless like
it's just one person after another
bidding on you know a pair of his cowboy
boots or something
and um
this couple came in and sat down next to
me kind of excited you know they had
just arrived the bidding had already
started
and the woman
at some point asked me what i thought i
was going to bid for and you know like
you say i was a poor assistant professor
at the time there was pretty much
nothing i could afford
so i sheepishly said well i'm just here
as a historian you know and then that
kind of piqued her interest and she
asked me you know why would historian be
interested in
johnny cash when i said something about
the vietnam war and she kind of cut me
off and said well anybody who knows
anything about johnny cash knows he was
republican right
i said well i don't i don't know about
that i think people might have different
ideas about his political background and
i quoted from
the man in black you know about wearing
black for the poor and the beating down
and um
and she said oh well yeah sure but
that's because he was a christian you
know he cared about people obviously and
you know so we had this kind of like
friendly debate and it it
it only uh kind of affirmed this idea in
my head that i i should investigate this
further because i had read other cache
biographies i read his own uh
autobiography
and nobody had ever really grappled with
the politics of johnny cash in a way
that i thought was particularly
satisfying so and it was interesting
because you know there is this thing
where people who self describe
themselves as either republicans or
democrats or liberals or conservatives
they all kind of claim him um and so i
was interested in why that was too
uh you you describe in the book some
fascinating early experiences that
johnny cash had
that casual fans might not be aware of
that he grew up in tremendous
deprivation during the great depression
his older brother who he loved a lot
died in a freakish and gruesome and
bizarre accident
and then during world war ii and shortly
after the war he was a co-breaker for
the united states military where he
played a really important role
and i was just curious you know which of
the formative experiences in johnny
cash's life do you think might have
played the biggest role in in shaping
his his politics and his his artistry
i mean it's hard to say which one of all
of those
was the most important um i would
probably lean forward saying that it was
growing up in poverty and witness to
real poverty and deprivation around him
you know his family was
much more fortunate than a lot of other
impoverished families in northeast
arkansas at the time you know he was
surrounded by
uh you know an enormous population of
landless farmers sharecroppers who were
really destitute and his fam his family
at least had the benefit
of being helped by the roosevelt
administration to be resettled in a new
community where they were loaned
you know the resources to get themselves
back on their feet
so a kind of combination of those things
is really important but
part of that too is the wartime
experience that you describe where he
his brother died not at war but during
the war making extra money for the
family um still because of their
enduring poverty during the war um and
then he
you know he serves in the military like
you say in the early cold war
and has you know a working man's kind of
uh veterans experience you know because
he was basically
joins the air force as soon as the
korean war breaks out because had he not
he would have been drafted for sure
and so i think he has a real empathy and
sympathy for people
who find themselves in these kinds of
circumstances which are not really of
their own choosing um and which are
controlled the forces which are
controlled by others you know
both my
my mother and my grandmother were johnny
johnny cash fans to some degree i was
telling you that the other day that i i
think i have very early childhood
memories of watching some johnny cash
specials with our family
um and at one time there was a johnny
cash autograph in our house which is
strange if we know my family because we
don't collect memorabilia and they're
not really
neither of my parents were deeply in the
pop music because they loved johnny cash
and
um they would watch that show
and uh and yet at the same time they
were not political in any conventional
sense certainly my mother and my
grandmother would vote but that would be
about it
um but you suggest that that show
sometimes would
carry subversive messages that that
might have still resonate with people in
ways that maybe even they didn't they
didn't understood um
what are some of the ways that the show
could have been subversively
political
i mean subversive
i'm not sure i would use the term
subversive um like i get the impression
from talking to a lot of people who
watched that show
including some of my older siblings that
they felt like
the the subversive thing was that he
brought on these young
uh radical artists you know to perform
alongside kind of mainstream country
music stars
but i don't i i think in the way that
cash
engaged with the public
and what made him popular probably with
your grandmother and mother who didn't
think of themselves as particularly
political
was that
he
was on this he had this television show
that appeared every single week and
practically every week
he weighed in in one way or another
on some of the most pressing issues that
we're facing the country
and he did it in a way that was kind of
very open
and not heavy-handed you know not like
this is what i believe and this is what
you should think i'm not you know trying
to force some ideological line on you
and he came across as a guy who was
trying to make sense
of really complicated political
circumstances in the way that a lot of
his viewers were right
and i think that really resonated and so
it doesn't come off for you know on
first glance you could watch some of
these episodes and think well you know
isn't that nice that he's talking about
young people you know who are
who are you know questioning the wisdom
of their elders or maybe not maybe you
know it's nice that he's saying
something positive about servicemen
or about prisoners or something you know
and he had these various ways on the
television show
of
introducing discussion about these
issues that were important to him but
like i say not in a way
where he was kind of forcing it down
anybody's throat you know so it didn't
feel like
he was out waving a political campaign
banner or was you know marching at the
front of a march it was just like he was
a citizen
and he was doing what he thought
citizens should do which is that they
should consider these issues
thoughtfully you know and weigh them for
themselves um
and so that i think that's really
that platform and that television show
are enormously important important to
understanding him as a public citizen
you know without that platform
there's other there's other ways that he
engages political issues but the tv show
for those you know
from 1969 to 1971 is the primary
platform
the
the topic of johnny cash and race
relations is a complicated one and i
appreciated the sensitivity with which
you
addressed it
um we obviously cannot call johnny cash
the civil rights hero
and in fact you describe an episode in
the book that i was not aware of it's a
grotesque episode when he behaved very
shamefully i don't know if you care to
discuss it but you also describe him as
someone who is able
to develop a capacity for for
transcending or overcoming some of the
racism in his midst uh how do you
what can you say about that that fraught
topic
well
i could say a lot um
he's uh
because it is a complicated story right
he he grows up in northeastern arkansas
in a community that's entirely white
that's deliberately
segregated i mean established by
a government agency
that
expressly said we're not going to go
against local norms right much as we
might like to so we're not going to try
to establish like an integrated farm
community here right
um and it's clear that he grows up among
racists uh there are people in his
family
tree who are racists maybe an uncle who
may have been a member of the clan
he certainly has confederate
ancestry right
and that's an important part of his
identity and then
we know because of letters that were
published by his first wife in her
memoir
that he had these particularly ugly
episodes that you referred to
when
he'd get drunk in
germany when he was in the air force and
got into these
altercations it doesn't seem like they
ever got physical but altercations with
black servicemen and then he recounts
these back to her
in particularly grotesque language you
know the language of racists
so it's safe to say that by the time you
know as a young man he's
he's a racist he hasn't shaken himself
loose with these
racist attitudes right
but then a few things happen
in the years after he gets out of the
air force one is that he moves to
memphis right this town that's majority
black population and he can spend you
know whole days in a way that he never
had in his life before
um
encountering no one but black people
including poor black people who he is a
salesman was meant to be selling things
to and who he starts to relate to and
starts to see
a kind of shared experience in their
poverty and deprivation that he relates
to
his own uh upbringing
but the other thing is really important
is that he becomes
kind of obsessed with these field
recordings that you know alan lomax and
others did
and particularly this one record that
came out in 1959 called blues in the
mississippi night which is one of the
most explosive i think most explosive
recordings ever to come out on a
on vinyl in the united states describing
segregation from the perspective of
these three
blues artists who are so
uh scared of this record coming out and
their families facing retaliation that
they insist that pseudonyms be used
right
and it's at that point you can see that
cash in his own work he starts to record
some of the same songs right and he
starts to develop this sense
of
kind of a low maxian sense himself a
commitment to social realism into
documenting reality
so what i describe in the book is not
really him
in say 1962
running to the front of the civil rights
march but instead putting out a record
called blood sweat and tears which we
usually think of as like
a kind of folk record with a bunch of
work songs on it but in fact
most of the work songs are about
exploited black men being terrorized
right uh subjects to horrific violence
lynchings right and some of these songs
he first heard
on blues and the mississippi night
and so i think it's that kind of
commitment to documenting
the social reality which he had seen
around him he'd seen
this in various ways he'd seen chain
gangs he'd seen sharecroppers abused
right um
that
you know he undergoes a really important
kind of transformation across that
period of the 50s and 60s so by the time
he has the television show
he's you know pretty much
an obvious advocate for racial equality
in the way that he presents race on the
television show
so you ever was he ever called to
account for those letters when did they
come out and did he ever have to answer
for him he never did because they they
came out after he died that that book
that uh vivian um
cash's first wife put out came out in
fact after she had passed just after she
passed away in 2008
um
so they've you know i think cash fans
who read you know everything that's ever
come out about cash would be aware
of those letters
but they haven't
i don't think anybody's really dealt
with them in the question of race
in particular detail until now
it's interesting to think about because
sometimes when people are drunk they say
things that they they reveal something
that maybe they've repressed that's not
socially acceptable but other times
people say you know things that
just speak out nonsense and you give
them a pass if you look at the balance
of his life i think you do a good job of
treating that issue with sensitivity
yeah thank you um
his best known albums were his prison
albums those are the ones that i liked
the most and he clearly had a special
empathy or or bond with prisoners
but i don't know if people are aware of
how that develops i wonder if you could
you could discuss that
sure
i mean he
you know
he had spent some time in jail himself
right he died a few run-ins with the law
never spent more than a night or two in
jail um and he never went to prison
although there was
this was a widely held belief
uh even after the folsom prison record
came out people assumed that you he was
performing as a prisoner in the prison
you know would send letters to the
prison you know addressed to johnny cash
but he had never done prison time but he
had started performing at prisons
as early as 1957 and he did this kind of
quietly um
just relating again
to men who i think uh you know he
understood as being impoverished most of
the time a lot of them from the south
like he was
um
and
you know
getting the short end of the stick
sometimes in terms of their run-ins with
the law
and so he gave many concerts you know
without much fanfare
at prisons over the years he enjoyed
playing them
but as he talked about in interviews
later
you know it bothered him
to see the looks in their eyes like to
see the soul you know kind of drained
out of these human beings
who were in these places these horrible
places doing hard time
and so
part of what he wanted to do especially
with that first
at folsom prison record
was almost like alan lomax you know was
to document the sounds of the
institution itself and the sounds of the
prisoners
um themselves and
you can you can get cash fans arguing
pretty easily about which of the two
prison albums is the best one
and there's actually a third one uh that
he did in sweden but the the san quentin
and folsom ones are the famous ones
and to me the interesting thing about
the folsom record is that he doesn't
he doesn't really play
any of his hits like he he tailors the
setlist entirely to the experience of
the prisoners there's lots of songs
about prisons and of course he's not the
first country artist to write these
kinds of songs or play these kinds of
songs but he's the first one to play
these songs to the prisoners and capture
their reaction
on tape and so it's a little bit hard
for us to go back now because we're if
cash fans know these records so well and
they've been released a million
different ways and we have both uh
complete sets you know in the box set
that you can listen to but to go back
and listen to the original vinyl you
know from 1968 and listen to that record
fresh is really fascinating to think
about the context of the times when
you know you have a president
richard nixon who's run for office on a
law and order campaign the governor of
california where the prison was uh
located and the concert was performed as
ronald reagan also very much law and
order and then here's cash kind of you
know taking the side
of you know hardened criminals you know
um
so i think
that's a really interesting
example of his empathy you know the way
that he relates to people
um
even people who are clearly guilty of
horrible crimes you know
well part of what makes those records so
extraordinary to me is it's the
interaction with the audience the songs
are great but there's also the sort of
ambient noise and the responses that he
gets to his songs
and would you be willing to talk about
some of that some of those dynamics on
the records
yeah sure i mean he's you know there's a
there's a few songs on the records that
i think are
you know part of this is a product of
the way that the the producer and the
label um managed it like we know on the
on that on side two of the folsom record
that they edited in some songs from the
second set most of the record is made up
from the first set and they kind of
cleverly edit them in so there's a
there's a kind of rise fall rise thing
um going on where you have like a really
exciting song followed by a soft
reflective song you know followed by
another exciting song
um
and
but yeah you're right that he you know
the way that he
speaks to the prisoners in between the
songs is as important as the things that
he's singing you know so he clearly
aligns himself with them when you know
he's talking about the guards um or he's
asked for a drink of water you know and
they're slow to bring it to him and the
crowd starts jeering at the prison
personnel for not like treating their
guests better and
the sense that you have that they are
you know almost brothers behind bars is
very clear you know people wrote about
this time you know in uh i think cream
or magazine or circus magazines uh you
know a kind of rock and roll magazine
the writer was like you know where where
must this guy be at or maybe there's
rolling stone where must this guy be at
to be able to relate to these prisoners
in the way that he does and people
people
you know somebody like porter wagoner
had put out a prison themed record the
year before but it was all recorded in
the studio and it was all you know songs
about prison and he's dressed in you
know a striped
jumpsuit on the cover of the album
porter wagner is but you don't get a
sense like you do with cash
that you know he could be one of them
you know and that he relates to them
like brothers there's a video recording
of one of those shows where he's giving
what i
see what i take as a dirty or
exasperated look towards a prison warden
or a guard you know what yeah yeah
those are funny moments there's a tiny
detail in your book that probably no one
else besides me will ask about you said
that played with sometimes i'm variety
bill so he wasn't the only performer
and is it pop and he said that some of
the performers were strippers at the
prison
not possibly you must be true because
you wrote it well it's it's a story that
merle merle haggard recounted the story
many times that uh on new year's eve one
year um that the
warden at san quentin right meryl
haggard was convicted of
of armed robbery you know
and uh was serving time at san quentin
and cash came in as the headliner on a
bill that included other
country artists the collins kids for
example
which also seems like a kind of weird
thing to have these like teenagers
basically in this prison
um and then yeah i mean like you can
find merle haggard recount that story in
multiple places he said there were
strippers in from san francisco and yeah
it seems um
i was just unlikely and unwise but
i suppose that prison concerts have
fallen by the wayside i don't think this
is something people do too often anymore
or am i wrong well i don't know that's a
good question um
i don't know i i'm
[Music]
i feel like i heard of someone doing one
recently but i can't think of who that
is and cash himself
you know continued to do them
into the 80s but uh
he started to lose his enthusiasm
because
he as he said to the press many times he
felt like
his work
on behalf of prison reform
wasn't really working you know that he
didn't he didn't see any positive effect
coming from it there's a there's a
pretty great you can find it in the
university of or no the state of
california archives has a full concert
of him playing at uh soledad in about
1981 that's online
um
and that would have been one of the
later ones
i have some more substantive questions
but there's one little amusing tidbit
that i want to address
once wrote in his liner notes in your
book that you quote he says that he
could kill a jack rabbit with a bowie
knife from a distance of 40 yards
and so clearly this story is not
true
and then there are other instances when
he was not the world's most reliable
narrator uh in my own
when i was researching my book on the
beatles and the rolling stones i would
sometimes encounter things like this
there are stories that i wish were true
because they sound great right as a
historian we have to be very scrupulous
about not you know passing along things
that just strain credulity and so i
wonder how you dealt with this as a
scholar separating some of the lore and
the myth around around johnny cash from
from
from the historical facts
yeah well you know it's difficult as as
you know from working on the beatles and
stones there's
an enormous amount of mythology that
surrounds any of these super popular
artists and and a lot of it is
self-created or it's manufactured by the
label or by both you know
and um
that episode you know that line that you
mentioned where he says that he he he
could kill a jack rabbit from 40 yards
away with a bowie knife right
um
is in the it's it's in the liner notes
of the ballads of the true west album
right which is
uh one of a series of concept albums
that he did
uh during the early and mid 60s where he
was you know increasingly plunging into
deeper and deeper drug addiction
and the thing is that in some of those
albums it's clear and his manager even
attested to this that
you know
he didn't say so much as the drug
addiction helped him but it's clear that
he became kind of obsessed
with certain themes right in his
drug-addled state
and i can interrupt this real quick he
said it would be a very unlucky jack
rabbit that would perish from a drug
addict's toss of a bowie knife from that
distance right right which i you know i
think
everything about to me that i know
that's a very popular album with some
cash fans but to me it's one of the
weakest of the concept albums like it
has it's called balds of the true west
it has songs on it that are not even set
in the west they're set like in new
jersey
um and there's
you know there's this kind of
self mythology taking place in the liner
notes and that's you know i just
thought when i read it
i think you'd have to be really good at
throwing a bowie knife really practiced
to hit a jackrabbit an enormously quick
and instinctive animal and knowing that
he was in such a terrible way in terms
of his drug addiction it just seems
completely ridiculous right
so you have to be as a historian you
have to kind of be honest about that
kind of thing much as i
i wish it was true you know
um
in in 1970 uh richard nixon invited
johnny cash to the white house and they
met and johnny cash performed
and i can see why a person would want to
accept
a white house invitation but i can also
see why someone like johnny cash might
want to decline that particular one
chose to attend
but it was an interesting story so i
wondered if you would explain
the story of what happened
sure i mean it started because cash
went on television
at the beginning of the
second season or the first regular
season because the the first season of
the television show had been a summer
replacement season you know
and in uh january of 1970 he
at the beginning of the season he said
at one of these monologues that he often
gave at the end of the show that you
know we're thinking about peace
uh in this season and i and my family
stand behind
president nixon in his quest for peace
now this is really interesting for a lot
of reasons not least of which is that
there had been massive protests in the
couple of months before that episode
aired the big moratorium protests that
took place in washington in between
which president nixon had gone on
national television and given the famous
silent majority speech in which he kind
of
derided protesters right for being a
silent but vocal majority who were
humiliating the united states
so
you could read cash coming out you know
in an episode that was shortly taped
before january um and
sort of deciding that he's you know on
the side of nixon in where where this
national debate is taking place and he
had previously gone to vietnam and
performed for servicemen about a year
earlier
and even at that time um you know he had
he had told the servicemen in attendance
that he he
wasn't supportive of the anti-war
movement right calling them also a swear
word um
so
nixon of course
wasn't a natural johnny cash fan um
nixon kind of liked broadway show tunes
uh but somebody in his
uh white house staff informed him of
this and
invited him to the white house to
perform in april of 1970
and cash took the invitation you know
it's a kind of famous episode in the
history of
johnny cash's career and
in his political engagement because
there was this whole dust-up where
someone in the nixon
white house staff asked him to play a
couple of songs
like merle haggard's oaky from muskogee
and this really
awful kind of racist song by guy drake
called welfare cadillac that really you
know
mocks people on welfare
a couple pretty mean songs as far as
johnny cash was concerned and and he
wouldn't play him um
and he he kind of he did it gently you
know he refused to play them by saying
these aren't my songs i'm going to play
my set you know
um but then he goes and he plays his set
and at this it's really interesting
because if you listen to the whole
concert he starts off saying to this
audience of about 300 people of guests
who you know really
fought tooth and nail to get tickets to
this uh performance in the white house
that he they just want to bring
a little bit of the soul of the south to
the white house that evening
um
but about 20 minutes into the show he
kind of goes off script and starts
talking about you know young people
and questioning the wisdom of their
elders and he introduces this new song
called what is truth um which is all
about protesters and it's all about the
vietnam war it's very clear from the
lyrics where he talks about you know
kitten sunday teaching sunday school and
next year it might be his turn to lay
his life down
um
and we know from dan rather who was
there as a cbs news reporter that the
president seemed a little surprised that
here is this guy who just said on this
television show that he supports
you know my plans for peace and now he's
here
staying 10 feet away from me singing
this new song about young people
questioning their elders and then cash
says to him mr president we hope you
know that you can bring the boys home
faster or even sooner than you think you
can right um that wasn't part of the
script clearly
so
it makes for an interesting episode in
cash's engagement with the vietnam war
certainly
well you know through a lot of the book
you described this dynamic you describe
him you know making statements or
holding viewpoints in the 60s or 70s
that could be described as liberal or
even leftist but he also had this you
know really strong appeal to
conservative listeners and there are a
lot of those as well
and
don't take the question the wrong way i
think i agree with your analysis but you
know someone might say that like every
recording artist johnny cash cared about
his popular success
and we know that because early in his
career he allowed his record label to
guide some some decisions and
he appeared looking ridiculous in some
photographs for commercial purposes
i found it amusing that you mentioned
that in the johnny cash show
the producers had decided that
part of their formula would be to have
an attractive woman on the show every
night so that more people would attend
a view rather um so how do you know that
when johnny cash you know would
go back and forth between views that
should be considered conservative or
liberal that he wasn't
prevaricating and just simply trying to
to find ways to appeal to
as many people as he could because he
wanted them to to buy his records
right
it's a fair question because um as you
say you know
you
you might think that about any artist
right wants to keep wants to maintain
the largest audience possible and wants
to
you know is willing to maybe speak out
of both sides of their mouth so as not
to either offend
anybody
or
you know
maybe less cynically just wants to bring
everybody together you could make that
case you know
um
but i really looked for that you know i
really looked to find some evidence that
somewhere
either he or his manager
um
were
you know
worried about alienating some part of
their audience by him
talking about or speaking up on one
issue
or another and
as far as i can tell the evidence
doesn't exist you know i think
certainly by the time he had the
television show
he
was in a position to be much more
fearless about that anyway because he
already had this enormous audience you
know he was fantastically successful and
you know if he was
if he did think that maybe he was going
to alienate some part of it and lose it
you know it wasn't
going to cost him you know financially
necessarily or
in any way that would affect his own
sense of you know himself his
self-esteem his standing as an artist
but the thing is he was doing these
things you know that one might regard as
unpopular
even before that you know he he covers
that song custer
by peter lafarge on the on the bitter
tears album which is basically about the
massacre of custer's seventh cavalry
right um
at a time when you know the
where at the height of the cold war at
the start of the vietnam war the
escalation of the vietnam war it could
easily be misread
as a kind of anti-militarism um kind of
song
and he didn't think anything of it he
performs it on the television show with
buffy saint marie you know sort of
laughing through
the story about you know uh
what happens to george armstrong custer
which is pretty ugly um
so i i just don't
i think other people have kind of
assumed other scholars and biographers
have kind of assumed that that was part
of what he was doing by by dabbling in
folk music he was trying to expand his
audience into folk but
johnny cash didn't need to expand his
audience into folk you know he already
had an enormous following even without
very many hit songs in the 1960s
he was a columbia record star and
he was in a kind he had a
he had a
certain amount of freedom because of
that um to do what he wanted you know
the television show's a little bit
different because he didn't have
complete creative control over the
television show it was clear that he had
guests on who he would have rather not
had on you know a lot of hollywood types
that the
producers insisted on um
but we know that most of the musical
guests you know were his idea and a lot
of me had to push for over the
objections of some of the producers
so
bruce springsteen whom i'm a very big
fan of managed to have a very long
career where it was quite obvious where
his sympathies were politically in the
way that he would relate to people who
were downtrodden or oppressed but he
managed to go a very long time without i
don't think ever criticizing a
republican person by name until i think
the bush era and now the trump aaron i
think you're right
i think he finally had enough
yeah but johnny cash never went quite
that far i guess
no i don't i mean but it's possible that
you know there's a famous
story's been recounted in multiple
places of springsteen's uh
you know release of 41 shots right the
song about amadou dialo being shot down
by police
and that you know reporters reporting on
going to see him at play at giant
stadium you know not long after that and
certain springsteen fans you know when
he started to play that song turning
their back on him and then as soon as he
broke into some hit song they turned
around and we're cheering again and i
think you know fans have the capacity
to do that sometimes you know even if uh
you know they may be in love with an
artist for years and then
write a song
that they don't particularly care for
they might be willing to look the other
way because on balance they love
everything else you know and i think
that's possibly true with cash too you
know i was at the show with our mutual
friend jeremy varan at madison square
garden where he debuted that song all
right okay yeah um
we'll finish up in a minute and then let
some other people ask questions uh my
last one has to do with uh i was i was
struck by a blurb
on the book by uh historian beth bailey
and she says that history is written for
an era as much as about one
and you know johnny cash of course lived
through
a really difficult and tumultuous time
during the vietnam era
but now by thinking by many measures i
think we may be even more polarized and
divided than people were then
and i wonder how this affected your
approach to the writing i assume that i
don't even think about this book for a
long time but you must have done most of
the writing during the trump era
and so i wonder how that might have
shaped your approach and then
can comment into that
what are the lessons that maybe you
think we could or should draw from
johnny cash a person who did try to
transcend political labels in some
pretty fundamental ways
well you're right that i did i did think
about it um obviously is impossible not
to um and
it didn't have so much to do with you
know particular political figures so
much as it did with the way that we
talk about politics in the united states
and the
terms of debate and discussion that we
use right
um
you know one thing that drives me crazy
is
always speaking in these kind of binary
terms of some
you know like on election night
everything's red and blue and that's it
and you know someone's either a liberal
or a conservative or they're a democrat
or a republican
um and we know that you know
lots of people
don't fit squarely into any of those
categories even if they might self-label
themselves that way it all depends on
kind of the issues it's up for
discussion and
part of that discourse is that you know
in recent years
it's not uncommon to hear comic public
you know political commentators say that
we're living in
kind of unprecedented polarized times
to a historian that just drives you nuts
when people say unprecedented because
almost always you can find a precedent
um regardless of what we're talking
about and we can say i'm sorry we can
say nearly unprecedented can we
i mean i don't think so we had a civil
war you know
we refer we refer to the
60s as a as also you know michael kazan
in morris isseman's book is
um
you know america divided the civil war
years right talking about the 60s as the
civil war i think the people who lived
in these periods that were polarized
also thought of themselves as living in
unprecedentedly polarized times
so
it's it was impossible to write the book
without also thinking about that right
the thinking that in this in this period
of the vietnam war um which had clearly
divided the nation
of uh urban uprisings of campus
uprisings right of division over
um
you know
the generation gap right um over
uh crises and of faith for example right
that this is the way that this is the
way that public figures talked about the
united states in 1969 and 1771.
so
i think you know
cash
by inhabiting this politics of empathy
that existed outside or within you know
these categories that kind of straddled
these categories that we usually use to
talk about politics
is
useful for our times right it's useful
to remind us that we can talk about
politics
and political culture
outside of those terms of debate and
that we can
demand better you know of our public
commentators um to be more nuanced and
more subtle in the ways that they
discuss american politics and that
it's okay you know for all of us for our
children if they don't feel like they
fit a particular label or fit into a
particular political
box you know um and in that way i think
that's what beth bailey
spotted you know is that this is this is
a guy who has you know died 18 years ago
but uh in the way that he thought about
his citizenship
he he acted in a way
that is a model for our own times
terrific i think that's really well put
and uh that's i think that's the thing
that i like most about johnny cash and
the thing that i
i learned the most while reading the
book um so i appreciate that
i see
tony does that mean are you are you
going to moderate the questions
right well i want to remind folks that
they can put questions in the the q and
a box um but before we get to that
michael i was just going to ask if
johnny cash
wanted to use his television program to
to speak out
why not do it more
blatantly like perhaps the smothers
brothers
yeah
well i think one reason is the smothers
brothers
you know they uh
they kind of paid for it by facing the
cbs sensors all the time and
um
i think
that's that's perhaps one reason is that
you know that that preceded the cash
show and he was aware of it but i also
think it wasn't really
it wasn't in his temperament
to be so blatant you know um and in the
way that i was mentioning earlier where
he is kind of thinking out loud about
some of these issues you know in the way
that he would present it for example
a political question on his
ride this train segment where he would
take
viewers on this trip
to some place in america's past or some
other place in american life
and he would get try to get viewers to
kind of put themselves in the shoes of
other people
that he seemed much more comfortable
with now at times he could be pretty
direct about it in the case of native
americans for example
and in the case of prisoners
he did over time by the by the time we
get to the
end of his last season he's much more
direct about the way that he talks to
his viewers about those issues
but he was never
you know he never comes across as as
towing an ideological
line or a partisan line it's always
like i'm just a citizen thinking about
these things like you are and this is
what i think you know
one of our our viewers was asking
referred to the um cash's cover of the
cowboy jack clements novelty song one on
the right
is on the uh on the left in 65 and says
you know a song that parodies the
travails of musicians wading into
politics what do you feel are some of
the main milestones that later
radicalized him even to the point of
making his earlier recording of that
song seem
more like a
parody
well the interesting thing about that
song is he he performs that song on the
television show a couple of times um at
least twice that i can think of um and
one time he does it
with the uh the tennessee three his
backing band and carl perkins dressed up
in these kind of exaggerated hippie
costumes you know
and he kind of laughs after they perform
the song they perform right at the
opening of one of one of those episodes
and he goes uh you know tennessee flower
children or something like that you know
so he's still
i mean it's very interesting because
that song as you say that jack clement
wrote
is
effectively you know takes a shot at all
the political folk singers the kind of
fill oaks of the world
saying you know keep your politics to
yourself is a line in the song you know
when it comes to singing the folk songs
of our land you know keep the politics
of yourself
and cash was able to you know still
perform that song on his television show
still poke a little bit of fun you know
at folk singers and perhaps at himself
right um even at hippies you know
because he's got him dressed up in these
kind of exaggerated costumes
while at the same time defending young
people you know in this monologue he
gives about encountering lots of young
people on the sunset strip in los
angeles and finding that they're like
decent people you know that if you had
crowds like that in his town growing up
there had been a fight every 20 feet but
that doesn't happen you know in what he
saw out on the sunset strip
so
he's able to
he's still able to have a laugh you know
and poke a little bit of fun
but it's clear from the way that he
he engages these political issues
across like a wide variety of political
issues and in many different ways on the
television show that he still takes
those things very seriously you know
how did other artists i mean you've got
lee greenwood singing you know god bless
the usa and as you mentioned merle
heightoky
how did artists like that
feel about johnny cash and his songs his
views
i mean for the most part you know he
because of the standing he had
particularly after the folsom prison
record and you know he wins all these
awards and he gets the television show
i think you know he's in the at that
moment he was in the pantheon of
american country music stars and they
held him in very high regard even if
they didn't
share exactly the same
views and
you know on the television show he
brought merle haggard on uh and merle
haggard sang oaky from muskogee and the
fight inside of me you know these songs
that were
seen as kind of like we'd call them dog
whistle songs today for american
conservatives and people who were hawks
you know and supported richard nixon
um
but on the same episode he debuted what
is truth right um and on an episode
where he let arlo guthrie sing this song
that's really critical of spiro agnew
and
the nixon administration
he then gave this monologue at the end
about how there were still a lot of
great things happening in this country
that they played a bunch of county fairs
that summer and you know people came
with their prized heifers and their
apple pies and he kind of like you know
launches himself into a nostalgia trip
you know um
so
i think
it was pretty hard for uh people who
didn't share his political views to feel
like
he didn't at least give him a chance to
air them you know on the same kind of
platform
and he had you know he had a wide range
of political views from other artists uh
that come through on the television show
of course he's his show so he gets the
last word
you know one of our viewers was asking
if you see an
artist who is reminds you of of johnny
cash today
i mean i see lots of artists you know
not only country music artists but if we
stick to country music there's a there's
quite a few who um i think take their
citizenship seriously and speak out on
political issues and because of
social media can do it you know even
more regularly
um
and across you know again a kind of
across the political spectrum and kind
of um
in between categories too you know um
i think my favor my personal favorite
was because i was asked this once uh is
like if somebody there was somebody in
country music today who could have a
television show like this who would i
pick
and i said margot price
because i think margot price does
the same kind of subtle
like engaged
citizen kind of art
in her music
um she's she's more of like a mix of
johnny cash and
willie nelson and loretta lynn probably
in the way that she she captures you
know
uh issues about or engages with issues
that are important to women engages
issues about farming because she came
from a farm that was lost in the 80s
farm crisis and
her marijuana advocacy like willie
nelson you know um
and i think and also in the way that she
kind of stands separate from
the nashville establishment you know
that's my personal view but i think you
know there's lots of other artists who
are also doing the same
kind of work um and that's a encouraging
sign you know i think the worst thing
that can happen as i allude in the
book's introduction is
is that people can have a knee-jerk
reaction
to celebrities um and even the most
earnest and well-informed artists
because they feel like
they're just you know abusing their
platform as a star or something and it's
just like you know go back to singing or
whatever it is you do
um
but you know and springsteen for example
has been very eloquent about
saying that the artist has an important
role to play
an important role as a citizen to play
in the life of the country and i think
cash understood that extinctively
instinctively
one of one of our viewers was asking
why you think
at times cash would speak bolder than
other artists but then would still
sometimes pull as punches uh in how he
phrased his
criticisms yeah that's a really
interesting question i think you know
one of the things that um
became clear to me in doing the research
uh for the book was that he
you know he enters these waters
um pretty tentatively like for example
on that blood sweat and tears album
um
where you know it it can be no accident
that he makes the first three songs on
that album
this kind of harrowing tale of black
working men in america right but he
doesn't really call attention to it sort
of like playing the prison concerts and
benefit shows he's not like waving his
hands saying i'm out here doing this
but over the course of the 60s and by
the time he has his television show he
becomes
more
um confident you know in speaking out as
a citizen and he said himself
that by the time he did the bitter tears
album which is only a few years after
the blood sweat and tears album he was
done
pulling his punches
i don't think that's entirely true
because he did kind of pull his punches
a little bit on things like vietnam and
i think you could watch the tv show or
read his statements and wish
you know as a cash fan who feels one way
or another about a political issue that
he had been
more bold that he had spoken out more
strongly or perhaps less
tritely at times on certain issues um
and you know why he did or did not do
that i think is not always entirely
clear but i think by the time he got to
the television show um and across the
years of the television show he grew
increasingly confident in the role you
know
i was wondering
looking at your book cover you have cash
wrapping himself in the american flag
and
the way our politics is now
one would assume
that is a very
conservative
view i mean you would you would put him
in the red stakes state
i was just curious about the the choice
that you and your editors had for the
the cover
well the choice
there's there's a lot of photographs of
johnny cash in flags
right he he's he made a couple of albums
in the 70s ragged old flag album and
an album that's called america
you know a 200 years
salute
in
song
i'm getting the subtitle wrong
but both of those he appears with the
american flag and the ragged old flag
it really is a ragged old flag hanging
behind him and he's kind of pointing at
it and looking at you the viewer
but i think you know
obviously the flag
is this symbol that is uh loaded with
meaning and we can read it in lots of
different ways um and in the cover of
the book
to me what's interesting is he's holding
up this flag that's kind of torn
and tattered you know this is not a flag
that uh he's about to fly up the
flagpole and he himself looks a little
torn and tattered you know
and it's
you know i think it reflects
in the early 70s when the photograph was
taken you know the state of the union
and uh perhaps the state of american
citizenship i mean mostly we thought it
was really bold image and a great image
to go with the title like citizen cache
but
it also reflects kind of the ways that
you can
read different meanings into cash in his
politics and the way that that has
happened right it's hard to
separate it sometimes as that woman at
the
at the auction house and i debated over
ragged old flag um
you know she thought that was clear
evidence that
he was a died in the wool patriot you
know um
and others think that song is you know a
critique
of americ of the america that he was
living in at the time you know um
and what had happened to the flag during
the watergate years for example
i really agree with you just to jump in
i've i'm stuck by captivated by this
picture i've looked at it a lot
and
yes for some reason conservatives are
more prone to waving flags but this is
it's in black and white
he's dressed in black there's something
about his visage and expression that is
a little inscrutable and it's really not
clear what's being signified in this
thing i think it's one of these it's
worse how do you say it research a
rorschach test right
in different ways but i was i've been
mesmerized by that yeah
michael did did your views of johnny
cash change
throughout your research
i mean if you go back to the you know to
the very beginning where i was a you
know kind of late-breaking cash fan like
my my memory of johnny cash when i was a
kid is similar to john's like i
remembered him
doing these television specials which i
thought were kind of geared towards you
know my parents and older generations
and i didn't i didn't get some of the
cornball humor and i just i didn't
really get him you know um i didn't know
anything about his son record years and
in those days it took until
the 90s when the american recordings
albums came out and i i went back and
listened to the sun records and prison
albums and things like that and i became
a pretty passionate cash fan but you
know the thing that
what got me started was the vietnam war
because that was where i had done all my
research and
i had written this article that came out
several years ago
wasn't really thinking that i was ever
going to write a book and so the thing
that i really learned in the course of
writing the book
was just how deeply he was engaged
across all of these different issues
including and especially civil rights
right including on race because uh
he himself never really wrote about it
in or wrote very little about it in his
autobiographies
and his other biographers didn't have
much to say in fact he was often kind of
criticized for being very outspoken on
behalf of native americans and not
saying much about african americans um
but then as it turns out and as i
explained there's a whole chapter
dedicated to cash and race um
he was deeply committed to understanding
the issue and to and to engaging it as a
public citizen um and so that was
probably the biggest
surprise to me you know
one i want to ask one last question if
you
if you had an opportunity to sit down
with johnny cash
and ask him a question what would you
what would you ask him
well
there are so many questions um
i mean so just not to
not to beat a dead horse and stick with
the same theme but you know i'm
interested in the decisions that he made
about making that blood sweat and tears
album and specifically
he makes lyrical decisions he he updates
the lyrics in some of these songs which
are you know were like lead belly songs
or famous folk songs or
in the case of another man done gone um
were was a song you would only have
heard on alan lomax recording
and i kind of chart the way that other
artists you know updated the song and
added their lyrics um
but cash never really talked about it he
never he never said yeah this is why i
decided to add this line or that line
and then another man done gone he makes
that song
even more frightening than it's ever
been recorded ever before
and i would love to just talk to him
about that you know about what was
happening
uh in his life in his mind in america at
the time that made him decide to take
this already pretty scary song and make
it even scarier
you'll have everybody all have an
opportunity to to learn more about
johnny cash the book is citizen cash
michael stewart foley i want to thank
you thank john mcmillan a cappella books
has the uh has copies of citizen cash
with uh an autographed book played in
inside so you want to get it there uh
gentlemen thank you all very much i
enjoyed this uh immensely
thank you thank you
and join us next time and check out
acapella books uh events for other uh
events author events that are coming up
thank you all and have a good evening
here's a look at books being published
this week
in lincoln and the fight for peace cnn's
john avlon looks at president lincoln's
efforts to bring the country